something happened along the way where
she ended up like this and I want to
know what those pieces are and why it
happened that way I'm like the opposite
dude you know what I think I go
Mussolini Hitler Mao all these [ __ ]
were once little children which one of
these [ __ ] kids are gonna be a
[ __ ] I deconstruct the other way oh I
guess that I'm like damn did you used to
be a baby what the [ __ ] happened in your
life man like what the [ __ ] led up to
this point because as we get older to
the the biggest thing that's been
hitting me now especially because we're
finding out a lot about ourselves as all
these habits that we have were developed
at a young age yeah just don't [ __ ]
know oh man it is I mean I think it's a
I think that's the base of
psychoanalysis I think it's cycle and
now yeah there's a there's a there's a
psychology method where they believe
that we go throughout life just trying
to figure out all the [ __ ] that
happened to us as kids mhm and we just
got to rework all that trauma yeah and
and you spend the most of your adult
years just trying to identify and rework
that and some people they live blind for
the rest of our lives you know yeah I I
definitely I don't know what it is maybe
as I as we get older we get a little
more empathetic like I definitely do do
man I'm [ __ ] everything makes me tear
up now dude I'm soft this [ __ ] bro I'm
like oh [ __ ] war testosterone is kind of
like chilling out too and you know what
I think it is is that we're starting to
see like oh kids I was a kid I could
make kids cuz guys are stupid like we
think ass stick my dick in the ass dough
yeah you don't think that's that's a
titty and a baby drinks out of that yeah
you think that's a titty I want it in my
face yeah yeah and or like it's it we're
very short-sighted like we know okay I
know like having sex can pop a baby out
but like do you really no do you really
like guys don't think like that
[ __ ] condoms feel terrible super
short-sighted I think we're there
very were like goldfish right if it's
not in front of our face we don't make
those connections until you become old
wise man dude I saw a video on Twitter
this kid jacking off on a plane do you
see a [ __ ] yeah yeah whatever we had the
blanket like this and you're doing like
that this fool was beating his dick like
it owed it money did this [ __ ]
was jacking off so [ __ ] good
dude did you see the the trail of videos
under that of other people jacking off
on the airplane oh she was a bald guy
that was beating off in his like hey hey
you bought by the [ __ ] stop that [ __ ]
right now stop little old guy yeah well
he was like maybe in his 40s or
something see that's so weird because he
was just like bald like like a nerd and
yeah I can imagine a teenager doing that
because ladies if you don't understand
when it's a teenage boy there's urges
that they had they had the hardest time
controlling man so like for me when I
see that type of [ __ ] and people like
don't you miss it when you were young no
I do not
I said I'm surprised that there's not
more teen pregnancies oh dude this kid
was beating his dick so [ __ ] hard
I've never seen somebody masturbate like
that it was almost like the first time
you ever masturbated ever like he just
bought his dick he left the window
slightly open so the [ __ ] light was
shining through hit the blanket so all
you see is somewhat of this kid just
mashing his dick like a bunch of [ __ ]
English peas turning the [ __ ] bottle
that [ __ ] was crazy he's so funny
because he thought that just we're just
having that blanket over him but still
beating off would hide everything dude
do you remember the first time you
masturbated nah I don't remember the
first time you was funny I couldn't
remember for the longest time and I
remember on a JK news Bart was talking
about the first time he masks but he
yeah I remember the first time and then
after a while I don't know what but you
know when you have conversation it like
ignites some type of synapses right yeah
so I remembered the first time I
masturbated [ __ ] after jump art kept
talking about I was like so I remember
the first time I masturbated the first
time I came it hurt yeah I remember I
was dry heaving yeah I remember they're
like not the first time I came by
we're coming back in those days I
remember it hurt oh yeah what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] [ __ ] never feel weird
after yeah yeah it's not because you get
a boner again yeah then like I remember
like wet dreams and all this other [ __ ]
oh yeah I should [ __ ] sucked as a kid
dude it did especially if you just crazy
[ __ ] horny man like I feel like if
kids didn't have porn today or like what
the [ __ ] did they do back in the day it
everything that's why kids were getting
married and [ __ ] having babies at 14
15 years old well I think all those
[ __ ] high-lows [ __ ] hardcore
Christian kids getting married early so
they kept up they just trying to put
without God judging people yeah look at
these [ __ ] dude like I don't
you ain't full of no body dude you were
literally getting married so you could
[ __ ] the eyes of the Lord dude like
this dude's out they'll get married like
17 and all of a sudden it's like [ __ ]
all the time and I'm like look at you
you just wanted to [ __ ] and now your
marriage is all messed up and [ __ ]
because they just wanted to [ __ ] do
it real quick they wanted to [ __ ]
without the guilt yeah I mean that's why
I'm like I think y'all should just get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] out but do it do it
when you're older like jackoff as much
as you can cuz be careful with that [ __ ]
man didn't know the month the moment my
kid starts jacking off and icy crust on
their underwear they're doing their own
laundry
[ __ ] picking up their boxers and it
looks like a [ __ ] like a plastic
plate I'm like [ __ ] you do your own
laundry now man [ __ ] disgusting
creature
hey bad [ __ ] jacking off is like a sport
though like I think it's funny like how
much you do that [ __ ] in your teens and
a much time you spend like if I spent
all that time actually doing my homework
and becoming smarter I would have been
so much more successful but it's hard to
think that you don't masturbate bro it
is dude I'm just trying to read a
[ __ ] sentence and I go three
sentences and I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
jacking off it's like reading the Bible
verse two in the beginning [ __ ] my dick
yeah I'm like trying to type a [ __ ]
essay and I'm on the I'm on the computer
and then
next minute my pants her mom around my
ankles I'm [ __ ] jacking off like a
[ __ ] and in the next minute I'm
taking a [ __ ] nap cuz I just jacked
off were you there when they when Nick
told that story about him jacking off
when he was a kid it he's got caught he
got caught with the when your dad was
height stop jacking up cuz this fool was
so loud with it inside the shower like
stop jacking off the how loud were you
jacking off Nick with all the hair all
yours like Nick cut that [ __ ] out dude I
can hear it it's [ __ ] disgusting oh
my god so when we were cavemen right I
think like see this is a good thing that
girls are like more cautious when
they're younger yeah cuz if girls were
just as crazy horny as boys oh my god we
would be having kids all over at like 13
14
oh for sure all over for sure died I
can't I'm pretty sure that if I had sex
like during high school cuz I had the
first time I had sex was I was when I
was 18 and it was after I graduated so
I'm pretty sure I would have had a kid
cuz of how reckless I was even after 18
I'm surprised I didn't have a kid then
and every girl you get with you think
they're the love of your life and you're
gonna marry them forever so you just you
just stupid my very first girlfriend I
thought that she was it I was like you
are the last person that I will ever
have sex with and I'm gonna have kids
with you we're gonna have that he's
house feelings these [ __ ] feelings
man
it's weird too because sometimes like
randomly out of nowhere like I'll have a
dream and she pops in my dream like my
very and I don't even remember what she
I haven't seen her since I was like 20
years old hell and it's so random like
she your girlfriend at the time or you
guys just kind of in the dream no no no
like back then was your girlfriend or
you guys just kind of hooked up oh no
she was my girlfriend the first person I
ever had sex was was my actual
girlfriend so he's got a weird like when
she pops up in in a dream but it's not
even like we're together she's there and
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here
but teen the teen sex though wasn't even
as good cuz it's like you don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm pretty sure she had
the woot out of the words yeah you know
life you come so fast I mean even in my
30s I come so fast
even faster as a team dude it's too it's
too [ __ ] sensitive dude you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing like I
don't know and I have no idea what I was
doing yeah
but the first time I actually probably I
got checked during sex about after sex
it was just one Filipino girl and she
told me I wasn't good and after that I
was like well you tell me what's good
then you [ __ ] tell me [ __ ] and then
you know she just was very open I mean
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
what the great thing that came out of
that was the communication that happened
after now that bull I started asking
like what they like what would they
prefer what they don't like just let me
know but a lot of girls wouldn't like
the first girlfriend that I was with
because there's Shane right yeah they
don't want to feel like a ho and all
that so I think that's why sex gets
better when you're older because you
don't feel comfortable with each other
it's you can't have good sex
yeah and for yeah I said definitely with
when I look back on it like I don't know
what I was doing she didn't know what
she was doing and I just thought like
yellow my dicks inside you it probably
feels great because my penis feels just
like [ __ ] and this is dirty little fat
boy that she was having sex with Gracie
little fat [ __ ] when guys get better
with age though I think for sure man and
I think like when I look back on it as
like dude I was I was disgusting man
[ __ ] disgust you she was having sex
with a homeless person that she didn't
even know oh they're so nice she got the
worst version of me let me tell you lady
if you had it now maybe a little bit
better just a little bit I last a little
longer and now I stroked the back of
your head with the back of my head like
oh man oh yeah oh yeah the back of her
head now did you do that teen [ __ ] you
just go and [ __ ] pump away and then
you [ __ ] nut didn't you just fall
asleep I know man it was just so bad
like I look back on it I'm like damn you
just really didn't care man like you
just wanted to get it in as much yeah
it's like one step above jacking off I'm
so grossed - looks like hygiene wise
like oh god this is a teen you're just a
disgusting little creature I know I
don't even know how that even worked out
damn girls our troopers man I think we
all didn't know what we wanted or what
what was a good standard yeah no it was
just like oh is this what sex is I guess
it is
now I'm like I gotta take a shower shave
my balls be sweating all day I feel bad
for you when you're licking it I'm like
[ __ ] hold on let me take a shower dude
back then it was like dude I would go
three days without a shower and get my
balls licked and [ __ ] I'm like I
don't care yeah people just she's like
that yeah of course what are you doing
yeah I mean they're [ __ ] like crazy
too you know and it's like [ __ ] dude